y sigamos con fútbol pero ahora en
nuestro continente porque en colombia se
está disputando la copa américa hoy fue
jornada sin partidos pero los equipos no
paran y siguen trabajando de cara a las
próximas fechas en esta ocasión nuestra
enviada especial estefanía montero
estuvo con las jugadoras de la selección
de paraguay que enfrentará a bolivia en
la tercera fecha del grupo a saludos a
estefanía que podemos esperar de esta
selección de paraguay mañana una
selección que pareciera haber encontrado
un nuevo rumbo tras su triunfo frente a
chile
los goles siempre van a ser los
protagonistas pero en esta copa américa
un torneo tan corto va a ser también
protagonista quienes impiden los goles
en el partido pasado frente a chile
todos tenían la mirada puesta en
cristiana en leer la figura de la
selección chilena pero de repente con el
pasar de los minutos a una protagonista
que se robó las miradas y los aplausos
alicia boadilla la arquera de la
selección paraguaya hablamos con ella en
el entrenamiento y le preguntamos cómo
está el equipo qué va a pasar en los
próximos partidos y qué esperan las
paraguayas
yo creo que fue un partido muy
importante para el plantel para el
equipo se hizo un esfuerzo
tremendo y yo creo que el resultado está
a la vista
de ahora se viene un partido bastante
difíciles y tenemos que sacar el mayor
puntaje posible yo creo que tenemos que
tratar de evitar
y recibir la mayor cantidad de goles
posible ahora
los partidos son bastante difíciles
los rivales son bastantes fuertes y yo
creo que va a estar un poco difícil pero
yo creo que estamos ajustando algunos
detalles que nos están costando
o sea que nos costó en el partido pasado
y yo creo que vamos a ir resolviendo
partido tras partido también eso
las paraguayas tienen la fe puesta en
que van a lograr ese tan anhelado cupo
al mundial por primera vez en su
historia no lo dude a un solo segundo y
mañana buscarán la segunda victoria en
este grupo
muchísimas gracias estefanía por todo
este reporte que estás haciendo desde la
ciudad de cali especialmente enfocada en
el grupo 'a' y ya veremos si las
paraguayas logran la historia